so nothing time now for CBS morning's
deals where we share items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts and during
this black history month we are also
showing you some products from black
owned businesses if you'd like to start
shopping now you can scan the QR code on
your screen there it is in the upper
left or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle
host Gail Bassey Norwell by now joins us
once again Gail what do we got here uh
but you know what I love these because
you have one I have one and these are
these computer stands this is the work
easy Pro this is the work easy
professional this is the CD4 these are
stands that can take the place of you
buying an expensive desk that lifts up
and lifts down or just having multiple
deaths terrific when the butt starts
hurting from so much yes you can get up
and get more done and you burn more
calories Gail if you just stand instead
of sit down okay so there's that so I
love it that's why we do the segment
standing up yeah of course of course and
I like this one because this one is so
lightweight it's portable so you can
move it to where you want to go you can
put your laptop on it it's a great place
for kids to study so if you've got kids
going off to college in the fall this is
something to think about or you have
your laptop on your desk you're watching
CBS mornings and your lap gets a little
bit hot by the time I show up well hey
you put it on this you can stand in your
kitchen and do this use it for recipes
it's a great thing to have and we also
have it for a great deal these start at
25.99 we have them for up to 42 percent
off wow that's good I like what you said
about recipes if you're in the kitchen I
thought that was good oh it gets out of
the spills though let me show you it's
easy to adjust to your height because
I'm a little height challenge compared
to some and so there you go oh that was
my fault Miguel I'd love to sit in bed
with that one on the left you can and
that's easy to do easy to do and there
you go you can make it even lower like
that just like that now talk about black
owned businesses this is this is very
special because she never gives
discounts you said that's right this is
who is she this is an exclusive from CBS
deals she doesn't offer discounts this
is from Theresa abaqua this this is from
Chelsea Paris people who wear these
shoes I have these yes yes
these These are an oldie but goodie oh
yeah these are at least over five years
old wow look at that yeah they're
quality too look at that they don't have
any scuffs look at the color beautiful
well they do have scarves well
that's on the bottom
yeah and we
exclusively we have the grace I like
this one and the black we have these for
somebody who's thinking of something
very very special for themselves people
like Taylor Swift wear them Beyonce so
the Beehive you want to jump in on this
she wears them yes Zendaya wears them
and even the great Gail King wears them
and I even have I have this pair on they
are very very comfortable and I the heel
is very manageable I could walk around
in these I can walk down yes I love them
and we have them for three what's the
lady's name uh Teresa she is they're
African comfortable yeah so comfortable
do they say African design European
style because it's it and these are the
kind of shoes that will last forever and
the price that's because they're pricey
they are pricey but they're 350. we have
them for 350 normally they're higher
than that so we have a great deal on
these we have them for 29 off so it's a
wonderful deal yet don't they feel like
I've never discounted before never never
they don't offer discounts so this is
the great crazy but I think we're worth
it okay and last
um oh no we have two things we have two
things let me switch places with you
here this is the rush charge power
station I really love this because I am
taking this camping this weekend we can
charge our phones with this if you are
in a power outage and you have a small
12 volt refrigerator and you need to
keep your medications cool yeah and you
need to refrigerate some water this is a
great thing to have this offers you
comfort and security so if you're going
to recharge your phones or that fridge
or let me turn it it is it is
substantial right there big but it does
big things right there see we're
charging my earphones and this phone at
the same time but look at this I'm going
to turn this around
this it is on I'm going to turn this on
so you can see it also has a flashlight
and if you keep flashing it gets
brighter and then it has a flashing
light so if you're stuck on the road
this is in your trunk yeah and you want
this because I thought you can find you
there you go what's the price the price
on this we have it for six hundred
dollars off all right yeah
so how much is it if it's 8.99 600 off
it's like 40 off allow me to be your
model oh yes here let me just step
behind here we go this is the Therma
Comfort yeah I love that Burleson this
morning it smells good feels good this
has Clay on the inside and an herbal
blend and you can put this in the
microwave warm it up for a couple of
minutes and you put it on that sore neck
and shoulder and you just get that
beautiful scent and you get relaxation
oh he's in the zone are you soothing in
the zone I don't like it and that
material is really plush it is plush and
it's three pounds so you will feel the
weight when you put it on to get that
relaxing purposes for sore muscles
we have this for 17.49 I mean it's great
30 off a great deal and you want to go
to CBS deals for all of these
cbsdeals.com especially the exclusive on
the boots and for 600 off the power
station no you had a good price range
today so you always do good variety and
good price range oh Gail yeah I have
friends who say we're all going to pitch
in and get somebody the boots for
somebody for Valentine's or if they're
going to give her something special
she'll be a group purchase Gail bass
thank you very much you don't want to
share shoes oh look I don't know what do
I know oh my god there are no shoes no
you don't want to partner with people
we're partnering with these companies to
get these deals we should point that out
and buy anything you saw today scan the
QR code on your screen there it is again
Tuesday I get to wear the shoes or head
over to cbsdeals.com to start shopping
now
get your own pair apparently we'll be
right how do you get Thursday